and i'm going to get married not
necessarily in that order but they are
going to live here what
i love you i love you michael i love you
too what are you even talking about i
was just talking about i farted
are you kidding me i did
oh my god this is
this is my place okay let's go back to
one this my friends is the master
bedroom check out the cathedral ceilings
those are like 17
feet high we have cable readiness right
there i'm going to totally pimp this
place out i'm going to put a surround
sound system i'm going to put a plasma
screen right against this wall terrible
put in my bed right over here no no no
no no this is a shared wall
neighbor throws his wife into the wall
plasma screen hits the floor totally
smashed well then i will get a warranty
indeed don't cover it bless her rip-off
well then i won't get a warrant so
that's the problem is solved
oh man
these babies are thin
michael is there anything you need from
me i'd like to go back to bed yeah joe
just get some rest to see you monday
unless you're still sick
um all right we'll have a great long
weekend i'll probably be just sweet
[Laughter]
you enjoyed that didn't you
can i do some of the talking i will do
the talking okay let him know that i'm
here what difference does it make
whether you're here hello hi oscar it's
michael
and dwight
yeah um i heard you were under the
weather
yeah i think i came down with the flu
really oh that is a shame you know it's
cleaning day here today
could have used some of that famous
hispanic cleaning ethic yeah i feel
terrible about it asking his symptoms
i'm on webmd what are your symptoms
uh i have the chills i'm feeling
nauseous and my head's killing
out michael is there anything you need
from me i'd like to go back to bed i
need you to go to bed i need you to get
better see you monday unless you're
still sick
so have a great long weekend i'll just
be asleep
enjoy to be fired i don't think he would
tell him really that i am far too
valuable to you
[Laughter]
fire who
i
i what who is he saying i can't really
make it out
it's fired wyatt you you know what those
are grounds
michael
look at me
[Music]
who do you think it should be jim
definitely no jim brings in money
phyllis
stanley
pam
oscar
meredith
kevin
angela it's not a popularity contest
although it does make sense to fire the
least popular because
it has the least effect on morale
one of the warehouse guys
what
there's someone left off that list
who who is he saying
you're right i didn't even think of him
no michael yeah that's actually a really
good idea no not me i could
not dwight i'm not saying that's what he
said i know that's what he said
what
tell him not dwight that is not a very
nice thing to say about him tell him to
stop are you kidding wyatt you i agree
he'd land on his feet make him be quiet
now i know what you're thinking
won't that just shed more light on the
penises but you know what
that's a risk
we have today
that is a risk that we have to no no no
i know what you're saying why don't you
keep going
hey i know what you're thinking won't
that just shed
i know what you're thinking won't that
just shed more light on the penises but
that is a risk we need to take
pam thank you
pam why don't you work with palace and
draw a picture of the
exposure this is a petition for the
business park to upgrade their security
cameras as well as install two
floodlights in the parking lot and i
know i know what you're thinking
won't that just shed more light on the
penises but that is a risk we have to
take pam you can draw kind of why don't
you work with phallus on drawing a
picture of the exposure that i can post
around the community phallus phyllis
sorry
i've got penises on the brain
back to work everybody i promise to give
authority back to you when this crisis
is over
do it
say it hey
turn your head over
do it
hey michael
give me control michael
i promise to give authority back to you
when this crisis is over
do it michael
do it hey
this office needs a strong man
say it
no soak
all right well man
you're gonna have to deal with this
yourself
what are you doing
stop it
i'm just stop spin i'm trying to confuse
your sense of direction
[Laughter]
as good a spot as any
what are you doing
stop it
i'm just start spin i'm trying to
confuse your sense of direction
we're gonna need a signal to bolt out of
there the slightest sign of danger okay
that signal is lift your lips
let me see
no no no like this
oh no oh dude i'm so sorry
oh
i'm so sorry dude okay we're gonna need
a signal to bolt out of there in case
there is danger and that signal is lick
your lips try it
no no no like this
okay
hey there gorgeous how you doing today
i'm good thank you how's it hanging
all right listen
my name
is
hey there gorgeous how you doing today
i'm good thank you how's it hanging all
right good listen my name is uh michael
scotch
and i just wanted to say
that uh i've got david wallace's son in
the trunk of my car if he doesn't get on
this phone in five seconds i'm gonna
start
what are you doing
god
oh my
god
david
hi stephanie it's michael scott again i
just spoke with michael scotch and the
sun's going to be returned everything's
fine
and i really really need to talk to
david
you